yeah so that's what we're doing we're
having a conversation
that's what uh-huh leave this fish I
think we we hey what is going on you two
now recently a subscriber asked David I
think i'ma kiss my girl for the first
time what should I do
what was it like when you first kissed a
girl were you nervous ah you think women
want to kiss me cuz they really don't
even my own girlfriend I have the briber
I'm [ __ ] around not the briber to
kiss me I pay her monthly but I remember
growing up like getting your first kiss
was something that everybody puts so
much emphasis on like if you didn't kiss
somebody by a certain time you were
considered a [ __ ] loser now for me
luckily enough I got kissed a lot
earlier than I expect not even kidding
you but like the first kiss wasn't
something that was that important to me
I mean it was important but not really
because I was super young and you know
those people they're not really kissing
you because they like you they just did
it because they were curious and I just
happen to be the lucky [ __ ] on the other
end a little did they know that I was
gonna grow up to look like this
not as QZ thought they were but I think
the kiss that makes you worry the most
is the first kiss that you get from the
girl that you like are not just like
somewhat like like hey what's up you
kind of got titties I got a penis hmm
but the girl that you thought about
every day when you were in class you
look at her she [ __ ] tosses her hair
yeah and then you fall asleep in class
you have a dream about making out with
her maybe having a little sex and then
you wake up in class you have a boner
and you can't get up you know the bell
rings and the teachers like David class
is over get the [ __ ] on out I would miss
the teacher but Monday card that ever
happened to you what me neither and I
think we put so much emphasis on that
first kiss with that person because we
think that that is going to be the basis
of what they think about us forever but
my very first girlfriend when I wanted
to kiss her it was something that I was
incredibly nervous about I was thinking
like will she like it am I gonna do this
too much is she going to reject me and
if she did reject my kids I thought I'll
gonna kill myself because obviously
everybody's first girlfriend is like
their first love because you had like
this imagination and you had this dream
of what it should be like and to me I
just didn't want to screw that up you
want to know what the funny thing is I
the first thing I think every guy thinks
about when they kissing a girl for the
first time it should I
you stung should I ease up slow up a
little bit are my lips chapped what the
[ __ ] is with my prick gun oh and by the
way if you meet a guy that says
otherwise you're a [ __ ] bitch-ass
[ __ ] liar yeah you know who the [ __ ]
you are you're the guy that telling
every other [ __ ] dude out there the
first time you did anything with a girl
you was [ __ ] no better [ __ ] you
thought you were [ __ ] dope when I
first kissed to go that [ __ ] knees got
weak like that [ __ ] her knees
didn't get weak she was trying to slide
away get the [ __ ] on out of here I'm
telling these kids that you were a
[ __ ] pimp and you knew exactly what
you're doing the first time that's
[ __ ] impossible stop that [ __ ] you
make kids freak out but in my personal
opinion I think you should use tongue on
a girl off on the first kiss especially
if you guys are sober and you ain't
trying to fight oh no lady this is where
you guys come in and you let a guy know
what they should do when they first kiss
because this is coming from a guy's
perspective guys think that they know a
lot more things than they actually
[ __ ] do but I remember when she first
kissed he was [ __ ] crazy because like
I just I saw these sparks in the sparkle
that like yeah and the reason why it was
like that is because you know she was my
first love and so that first kiss was
something that was very important to me
and obviously it was something that was
a lot more crazier in my head than it
actually was basically what I'm saying
is chill out it's not the end of the
world if you give her a kiss and it
doesn't feel the same way that you
wanted it to or you thought it in your
[ __ ] crazy head at your age and I was
a saying too I mean everything a big
[ __ ] deal oh my god my first kiss my
first dance what am I gonna wear to
school you'll find out that all that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] meaningless when you
stressed out about [ __ ] that's just
supposed to have it and supposed to be
really fun you're gonna make things a
lot worse for you I'll tell you
something that if you guys are worried
about what you look like when you kiss
trust me it's not as pretty as you
[ __ ] think and that's the movies
fault movies kind of had this way of
making you believe [ __ ] that's not
really true everybody think they look
like this
today but in reality you probably looked
like this hopefully not like that but
that's probably what I look like lucky
Mary oh and yeah till this day I still
remember my very first kiss with my very
first girlfriend it was something that
was absolutely amazing I did this thing
where we she was in my room and her head
on my lap and I kind of like spiderman
kissed her you know that outside - it
was [ __ ] hot I'm [ __ ] romantic
on another note - you want me to be
completely honest with you - at that
very moment when I first kissed her the
only thing I was thinking about was this
bitch's head is on my lap I hope my dick
don't stab her in the back of a brain
that's honestly for you love connection
ooh
hey what is going on YouTube if you guys
have more questions or more topics that
you guys want to ask me about it could
be articles it could be questions
motherfuckas I am here for you I'm here
to talk make you feel better about
yourself because [ __ ] I don't feel
good about what that's what is people
with family we're here to connect we're
here to talk we're here to get a little
saucy a little freaky I will see you
guys next week remember
let's connect keep talking to me let's
do this again I've got plenty of
opinions more videos David what was it
like when you first kissed a girl were
you nervous did you think about a lot of
weird things in your head huh it was
weird I can't even picture myself having
sex that's crazy huh